In 1848, Phineas Gage was working on a
railroad in Cavendish, packing the powder
down with a tamping iron, blowing up rocks.
The charge detonates prematurely and this
tamping iron, this three-foot seven-inch,
thirteen and a half pound tamping iron
fires into Phineas Gage's head.
It enters into his left cheek, it passes
behind his left eye, it severs his optic nerve,
and then comes out his forehead lands 30 yards away.
Phineas Gage was able to survive having
a three-foot seven-inch bar shot
transcranially through his head.
In 1850, Henry Jacob Bigelow.
professor of surgery at Harvard Medical School at the time.
brought Gage and John Harlow, his doctor, to
Harvard for an examination.
Bigelow essentially concludes that this man did have a giant iron bar shot through his head
and did survive, and he publishes the case in1850.
After the accident, Phineas Gage goes from business-like and efficient to
no longer able to follow through with his plans.
He becomes the textbook case
for post-traumatic personality change
and that's what you find in a lot of the
modern medical neuroscience psychology literature.
Phineas Gage has been at Harvard
Medical School for a hundred and sixty years
so in many ways I see him
similarly to how you would see one of
the famous professors who hang on the wall.
He's an important part of Harvard
Medical School's identity and by
Continuing to reflect on his case, it
allows us to continually change
how we want to understand the human brain how we
interact with our historical
understanding of neuroscience